the United States has begun
reconnaissance flights over Syria to
track Islamic state jihadis but insists
it has no plans to coordinate with Syria
on targeting the militants it's also
been revealed that President Assad's
ally Iran has supplied weapons and
ammunition to Iraqi Kurdish forces
battling the is fighters in northern
Iraq I'm joined now by arash Amish
national security analysts in San
Francisco in California welcome to Sky
News but can I ask you can the u.s.
safely carry out airstrikes in Syria
without cooperating with the Assad
regime given Syria sophisticated air
defense system I mean Saddam Hussein had
sophisticated air defense systems as
well but there are no match for american
airpower that's one thing but we don't
want to send our pilots into harm's way
without making sure that what we were
trying to achieve and a limited capacity
is going to put them in enormous danger
so if there is going to be any sort of
American involvement with through air
power and over Syria I would assume that
mr. Assad is at the very least not going
to engage American aircraft over his
airspace if you listen to our Waleed
Milan the syrian foreign minister's
speech yesterday he welcomed the idea of
a fighting terrorists with the united
states and with other countries now the
Syrian government has framed it civil
war for the most part as the as a war
between the Syrian regime in Damascus
and terrorists we do know that a good
chunk of these guys these jihadists
fighting in Syria are terrorists but
there is a legitimate opposition to high
sets a rule in Syria as well so we're
going to be careful with fat there it
definitely is an element of danger but
again let's not forget that the American
military hardware is unmatched and
unrivaled around the world so I would
worry to some extent about Syria defense
systems but it's not going to paralyze
us for carrying out reconnaissance and
later bombing missions over Syria well
moving from the united states to to
Iran's america's long sworn enemy what's
the significance of iran supplying arms
to the Kurds in Iraq Iran is there
trying to consolidate itself position in
Iraq because
former Iraqi government was a very
closely around the current program the
sort of prime minister-designate mr. our
body is very close to Iran Iran has also
had very good times with the two big
Kurdish parties of Iraq the Patriotic
Union and the Kurdish Democratic Party
so one belongs to mr. Barzani the
regional sort of leader president of the
Kurdish regional government and the auto
today through Jalal Talabani the former
president of Iraq Iran has had good
times with both parties why because Iran
used the Kurds and the Easter Kurdish
parties who were fighting against Saddam
Hussein's or you know rule over Iraq so
Iran is trying to provide these weapons
to do a couple of things first and
foremost to fill the vacuum and the gap
of our absence American and Western
absence that to this point we have not
yet delivered the exact amount of
equipment these guys need that's one
thing second Iran is also worried about
its own Kurdish population Iran doesn't
want Iranian Court Kurds who are now in
Iraqi Kurdistan to fight along Iraqi
Kurds fight Isis and that is why Iran is
providing something to the Iraqi Kurds
however also making threats not to let
Iranian Kurds fight alongside Iranian
Kurds I'm sorry Iraqi Kurds even I get
confused complicated I know I rush
aramesh thank you very much for talking
to us here at Sky News